*high pitched edited laugh*
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Super Mario Maker
Ok, and we're on a new set of levels
I'm about.... uh.... nine--oops
I was supposed to get that
Unless it's gonna be a vine--- nah I'll take the mushroom
Who needs fire flower? Fire flowers is for quitters!
W-who like to take the easy way out
Wait that's a perfect description of who I am and what I like to do
Why aren't I taking the fire flower? anyway, so this--
Is gonna be the second half of this and I'm gonna speeed my way through this
Because I'm a baller-shot caller-somethin' somethin' na na na na naller
Wait was that the end of the episode over there?
Was that the end of the level?
Wait a minute
Did I-
Did I- Did I just miss an opportunity to finish the level? Because that looks like-
Ohhh, there's a wooden block there, okay. So there's gotta be another way  to go around
Anyway, like I said:
Baller. Shot caller. Doing something hananana holler
I don't know how the rest of the song goes or if that's even part of the song or any song that I-
But ah, nevermind me
I'm no-I'm an idiot
And I should not
[gasp]
Hoooly crap
Did you guys see that?
Of course you saw it, you're watching the video.
But holy crap!
I'm really proud of myself
I don't even know if what I did was all that amazing
It was almost certainly pure LUCK but that doesn't matter to me
I like pure luck
Okay
Holy crap
I-I play veryyYYUUUHHHH
I did it!
Already!
I'm off to a blazingly good start
FLOOF THE HAIR!!
For additional power, not that I need any more at the moment but I'm doing fine... this is really cool
Yeah, I- I- I know that I said a while back that I was probably done with Mario Maker but this puts a new interesting spin on it!
Because this makes it fresh and unique because it's always throwing - super shovel bros?
It's always throwing new- hello.
Alright then
'Scuse me.
It's always throwing new and interesting stuff at me
And it's always of a variety of different levels and I don't have to, like-
I don't have to- I don't have to do the burden of picking the levels that I want to play
And I-I-I would like to rely on you guys for more of that stuff but at the same time,
like, it's sometimes hard to get them because you have to put in the code and that slows everything down
This is fast, blazing action - why had I not done this before, sooner?
So cool!
Dammit
eeh
Alright
Ehh - whoa woah whoa whoa woah woah woah woah whoa.
HEY whoa whoa
'Scuse me! I don't even want  to mess with you baby Bowser
Y'know I mess with your father enough
it's enough
for mee
Boink!
Ah shit
No my-! My- goddamnit I screwed myself
There we- Oh!
Oh I didn't know you could do that
Oh that's cool!
Okay, that works for me!
I knew you could toss 'em like that I didn't know you could just put em on there like that
C'mon, hurry up
Tired of waiting for these elevators... alright let's go
Where are we headed, where are we headed, where are we headed?
Where are we headed? This way?
Okay. I'm down with it
I'm down to clown
What's with the- What's with the time-gating mechanisms?
Uhh... up here? I- Okay! Alright then
(quietly) Where else are you gonna take me?
Eh. Oh? Right at the end here?
Yes. Yes! YES
Hehehehe
So cool!
And what's funny. I think it is like at, uh,
always at the end of these ones you will always get something.
unless it is only by the...
Based on whether you get the star or not
But I'm not a hundred percent sure on that one.
AAWWH I almost beat the world record
I was trying to go as fast as I could
Just didn't matter.
Fweeea!
Alright. Movin' right along
Bla [burp hiccup thing] -zing speed.
Nice eyes, Asher.
I didn't even catch the name of this one.
But it's a movin' one.
Just gonna keep -- Uh oh
Where...Wha wha whaaat?
[stunned silence]
Did I miss somethin'?
Am I --
Am I mistaken on this one that there was supposed to be something 'ere?
Oh, maybe... Oh.  Is there...?
Ah, yeah, that would make a lot more sense than me jumping off into the abyss.
[laughter]
The whole reason I did that was just so Mario would like
questioning every decision that he's made up until that point because he'd just start
jumping off a ledge into the abyss, trying to save the princess.
Whoa, hello
[death] Ooo-kay, never mind then!  I'm not supposed to move on that one.
I'm just supposed to let it "take me."
Alright, thanks Asher.
I think that said "The Rage of --" something.  Maybe this is finally going to be a difficult level.
Not that I was eagerly awaiting a difficult level.
Oh, look at that little Mario booty. -- Okay...
WHOA, what the frick is that?
Obviously, it's a fire stick.
Ok, moving along...
This time, we're not going to suck it up.
Just move, just carry -- CARRY ME!
CARRY ME!  Oh, hello!
That's the big ol' thrusty-doo.
AHH OH!
Do these eventually die?  Or am I just -- have I screwed myself over pretty badly...
Pretty sure I've screwed myself over.
Uh!
This is not fair.
How is this supposed to do?
How am I s'posed to -- N'oo-kay, got in there.
Woah-ho.  AH!
AH!
Oh god!  This is so scary!  Checkpoint!  Thank you!  yes please!
Oh gosh.  I'll need that.  I appreciate it.  You're the best.  Love you.  Mu-ahh!
WHEEEE!
I'm guessing in these are gunna be secret key doo-dads.
There must have been -- ooOOh, frick.
God dammit, why would you do THAT to me?
I wasn't ready for that!  Oh!  Hello!
Okay.  Thank you?  I guess?  Eugh.  Eugh!  Okay.  We're okay.
Everything's fine.  Everything's cool.  Everything's chill.  Where the hell am I?
Oh god...
Okay, let's try this again.
Hoo-boo-doo, boo-boo-doo.  Thank you!
I needed that!  I lost a couple clones, here and there.
It's time to get 'em back and replenished.
Man, I can only imagine what the hell Princess Peach is thinking right now.
I mean, there's so many, like, theories as to why she continually gets kidnapped.
OH GOD!
Don't you dare come after me you.... Flubby...NO. Oh.
[sigh of relief]
I almost had a heart attack
anyway...
I can only... There's been a lot of different theories as to why Princess Peach continuously gets kidnapped.
From, you know, the various ones saying that she's having a secret affair with King Bowser, er, King Koopa.
Speaking of which... OH!  I was NOOOT REEEEAAAADY!
GAAH!  Why would you do thaaat?!
I wasn't ready.  Now I have to go get the keys again!  Goddammit.
What a load of bull.
What a bull-honky, bull-load.
Alright, let's try this again.
*shakes head and sighs*
Aww, come on!  Screw you.
It's like it's ma -- Aww, fuck you.
Let's try this aGAIN!  With less stupid!
If I had the stupid spinney-doo, I'd be able to get right past Bowser and I wouldn't have to worry about it.
Even with his stupid chain chomp pet.
Wompy!
Blooop!  Thank you!
Okay. Let's try this again!  With less stupid!
How am I s'posed to be able to beat this guy?
Oh, am i suppossed to... ooh.  That's handy!
Thank you!
Whooa.  Almost got lost there.
Bowser:  ROAR!!
Mark:  AR-RAR!
Uh oh.  Alright, just take this.  *Whizzing*
Whooa - kay, we're good, we're good, we're good.  Oh god, that's not what I wanted.
Eu-uuh-uh-eh.  Okay.  Goodbye!  Goodbye, Bowser!  You have fun with all of your toys!
Where am I goin' now?
*ding*
*Whizzing*
WHOOO!
Oh, maybe there's like a... Ooh, is there a secret up there?
OOOH, is there a secret up here?  I bet there is!
Helloo!  Gimme, gimme, gimme!  Secret?
Secret?
Aww, dammit, there's nothing.  It's all just a big LIE!
Full of lies... BOINK!  At least I got the one-up, so that's nice.
Consolation prize on my misery.
Alright... that was a cool one!  That was really interesting.
It was a bit harder than the other ones but it was definitely interesting.
Alright.  GO GO GO!  Let's go.
"The Rage of Bowser."  Thaat's what it was.  Okay.
I'm with it.  I'm hip with it.  i'm hip to it.
Manually Designed Chao--? WHOA WHOA WHOA WHOA WHOA WHOA WHAT THE F--?
Can I have that back, please?!
Oh god, where I am now?
Manually designed chaos, my ASS!
What the hell is this?
Should have called this level...
GIANT MINDFUCK OF --
WHAT THE FRICK?
I'm outta here, I'm outta here, I'm outta here, I'm outta here
okay...
alrighty then...
What the hell? *chuckles*
Oh wow...
Some of these levels...
I just feel like someone just...
started screaming at their Wii tablet and just was like
"OH MAKE IT FOR ME!"
World record: two seconds?!
What the --
Was there just one of the doors that just led right to the end? Probably.
I-I didn't even read the level on that one.
Oh!
I'M a spring.
I'm a SPRING!
What does this mean th-- Hello, everybody!
Could I -- Oh god. Oh god please, just--
Please!
I'm begging you! I'm begging you!
I'm begging you just let me through!
Just please!
Why was I a spring for that?
I didn't even need to be a spring! I could have had anything at all!
Oh wow...
That was fun...
This was fun...
Been a while since I played
a game that had a lot of fun like this.
This is super fun.
So fun...
Man, I keep not --
What is this?
WHAT ARE YOU?
WHAT. ARE. YOU.
WHAT! ARE! YOU!
hello, little birdy,
what are you supposed to be doing for me?
Alright, whatever. Frig it. Stupid!
((ahdoneedaway)) AHHHHH NO!
OH!
SAVED IT! AH!
ALMOST KILLED IT!
OH GOD!
*creepy laugh*
*laughter in reverse*
Oh man, I panicked so much for no reason at all. *starts chuckling*
Oh, wow.
Thank you for the heart!
I don't know where I'm going!
Oh, god! I was close to the end there.
I panicked sooo much, I can't believe I made it out of there.
oh wow...
that was awesome.
Oh, that's awesome. *sniffs* Oh wow, that's awesome.
Okay, anyway...
"Piranha Kingdom"
I'm not 100% sure why?
I only saw like three piranhas, but then again my eyes were practically closed the entire time I was playing that level.
In fact, I'm not even sure I was playing. I think I just let go of the wheel.
*giggles*
Oh...
Thank you~
Oh classic Mario...
*mutters* Music is zat?
Eh
Ok...
Am I supposed to take a ride up here on somethin'?
Am I supposed to be doing something...
...incredibly important?
Ohp. Nope. Was supposed to go down on that one...
Ah! Ah! Oh, god I thought I- Uagh! Oh god
No! No! No! No!
Yes! Yes, I'm skilled! *slight lisping*
Take some of that!
Aww shit! *more lisping*
Waa goddammit, dude
Aw, frick
UAGH Don't taunt me! Aww, piss!
Doywuh
I- augh, I thought that was a checkpoint. I thought I was gonna get a 1-up!
I thought I was gonna get anything
man, I am sweating, I am too into this.
Hah, I can do this guys.
I can do this if you can just believe in me.
What? You don't believe in me??
Well then, why is that not a surprise? I'm not surprised you don't believe in me.
Even I don't believe in me, where am I going?
Oh god! I was not supposed to do that!
I thought that was supposed to be a skill-based thing when I bounce on the bullet!
Ah crap..
What was it, Schwartzel? Schwartzel?
Why was it called Schwartzel?
I dunno why it was called Schwartzel.
That is, someone in another language made it?
Someone from the Schwartzel region?
Come on, there we go.
Alright.
Boink!
Okay, now we're blazing speed.
Now we're blazing speed, and now I'ma have a showdown with these assbags here.
Don't even think about it!
Don't even think aboot..
Don't even think aboot it..
You never going to geet me..
Aw shit, they got me..
Boink..
Okay.
Hup!
Hep! Hoppa!
Alright. Whoa, shit.
Hoppa! Okay.
Now we're gonna go down the traditionally good way..
woops, never mind then.
What the frick is all this bullshit?
Okay. Can I..
please tell me there's something good in here.
Nope, it was a coin. Oh boy.
Alright. I don't even think..
Oh, you can.
Oh, okay, that's helpful.
Alright then.
Please tell me..aw no.
Fire flower? Is it gonna come out eventually?
Are you just yanking my yank?
You're just yanking my dank, aren't you?
There ain't gonna be no goddamn fire flower..
THANK YOU, there we go!
What took it so long?
Alright.
Eh.
Okay.
Yeah, there we go.
Alright, Bowser bitch.
Time to have a showdown with thishd--fuck.
Alright you know what? Fuck you.
Oh god.
Ah, no, no please..
Have mercy! Have mercy on me!
Have mercy! Oh have mercy!
Oh god, mercy! AAH!
Oh..
Why did my elevator leave meee?
This is so stupid.
Wanna go bro? You wanna go? Huh?
You wanna go bruh? Shit.
Oh welp. Time for plan B.
Oh god no, not again..
not again, not again, screw you!
I'm gonna go back! I'ma get a flower!
And then I'ma show you who's boss!
Huh!
You ain't gonna ever beat me!
No one ain't gonna beat me!
[powerup beeps]
You're not me.
Who do you think you are, me?
Fuck you.
Aw, god dammit! With the...
bullshit..
Stupid fire!
PIece of..crap..
Ass..okay, here's my ride.
My ride's a comin'!
I'm just gonna go for my riiiiide...
If you get dead, that's cool--
AH SHIT.
FUCK. GOD DAMMIT.
Alright! I'll catch ya next time!
Alright! I'ma really show you what for..
when I come back!
[laughs] When I come back for the 4th time!
It's really gonna be the end of the road for you!
I'ma just wait for my superpower up here.
Oh god, it's my ride..
Hoo boy. Wait! Come back!
Don't leave me! Ride!
Shit. Now you're gonna get it!
HA!
Now you're--FUCK.
God dammit! Again with this! Uagh!
I'll come back again! And then you'll really see!
See--aw, fuck!
No, I'm really gonna..I'll be back!
Fuck! Me! In this..bullshit...
But you're gonna get it this time!
Aw shit, my ride..
My goddamn ride!
Augh, come back, ride!
Fuck! Me!
No, don't fuck me, but..you know.
Kay. Now you're just gonna die.
I'm just gonna stand here, and you're gonna die.
And you're gonna--there you go, you died.
Oh look. It's my ride.
Now I take my ride up.
I'm definitely gonna be the world record on this one.
With the blazing speed at wi--with which I beat this.
Oh, I can just go down here.
Didn't know that.
Boink. Didn't even get the 1-up! Didn't need the 1-up!
Frankly, I thought I did good enough as it was!
I don't have anything with which to mop off my brow.
49 seconds, cheezus.
That is just gone straight for the end.
Ah, we're almost done.
Play through these..last few.
It's just..one word name.
Oh, what is this..
Oh, what is..what, I..shh--waa-
Ooohh..
Ok! Anyway, I actually- what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna stop there. I lost track of time.
I've actually been recording this episode for a lot longer than I intended.
So, I'ma end this here and I'm gonna finish this up in the next one and then do a couple special bonus levels
that you guys recommended at the end of it.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
I am having a ton of fun here, this is amazing.
So, thanks again everybody,
and as always,
I don't wanna know what those fireballs are,
that spells a lot of death for me in the near future,
but thanks again everybody.
And as always, I will see you..
in the next video.
Buh-bye!